vidual investors and examines techniques
used by corporations and Wall Street to
manipulate stock values this is a little
under an hour and 15 minutes good
evening and welcome my name is sue
Ashford and I'm the faculty directory of
the University of Michigan Business
School's Executive MBA program and we're
very happy you brave the weather and all
to come here tonight to hear the talk by
out there love it the Executive MBA
program brings together an exceptional
group of experienced managers interested
in supplementing their experience with
an MBA degree education and these
managers are exposed to many of our very
best faculty and they go through a
program that takes advantage of
information technology and the culture
that we create among them to create a
very exciting and flexible way to earn
the MBA degree tonight's event is one in
an ongoing series of speakers that the
Executive MBA program invites to the
school and on behalf of the Executive
MBA program I'd first like to thank
borders in pantheon press for sponsoring
tonight's event we're very appreciative
to them we're going to spend our time
together as follows our speaker will
make remarks for about a half hour and
then he's very interested in taking your
questions for about the same length of
time and after that he'll be available
for book signing to introduce our
speaker I'd like to bring up Jeanne
imhoff Jean Imhoff is the ernst & young
professor of accounting and a long time
faculty member in our business goal
please help me welcome ginia mom
thank you very much my pleasure to be
here 70 years ago in response to a lack
of public confidence in our capital
markets our congress created the
Securities and Exchange Commission and
the SEC has remained to this day the
primary agency responsible for
monitoring and oversight oversight of
our capital markets in 1973 president
clinton appointed Arthur Levitt as the
25th person to be the chairman of the
SEC prior to being appointed to the SEC
mr. Levitt served as chairman of the New
York City Economic Development
Corporation and then earlier as chairman
of the American Stock Exchange following
16 years of practical experience on Wall
Street he's a Phi Beta Kappa from
Williams College and a veteran in the
United States Air Force he served as
chairman of the Securities Exchange
Commission until early two thousand one
making him the longest-serving chairman
responsible for overseeing the quality
and integrity of our system of corporate
financial reporting today 70 years later
70-some years later the American public
is experiencing what might be the
greatest lack of public trust in our
capital market since the SEC was formed
so I think it's appropriate for us this
evening and as a part of this program to
have mr. Levitt here with us tonight
he's the author of a recently published
book detailing what Wall Street and
corporate America don't want the
investing public to know and will be
speaking to us about things that will
find a great interest given our our
backgrounds without further ado let me
introduce mr. Arthur Levitt
thank you very much i'm honored to be
here this evening i just ran into marina
Whitman who I have such enormous respect
for who was given so much to the
community and this institution is such a
special institution and this place is
such a special place that to be here has
great meaning for me and I thought that
I would share with you on an informal
basis how I got here why I wrote the
book that I did where I think our
country is today in terms of its economy
and what I think might happen in the
future what we as citizens and investors
might do I started just to give you some
perspective if I ask randomly what kind
of a background I had to bring me to the
Securities and Exchange Commission most
of you would say well he's a lawyer or
he's an accountant or perhaps he's an
academic well he's none of those things
he started his life as a drama critic
for the Berkshire Eagle in Pittsfield
Massachusetts
and following a stint in the Air Force I
went to work for Life magazine and
Cincinnati and after five years of
working for life and time someone
offered me a job in the cattle business
so i moved to kansas city missouri and i
sold cows and ranch land and
parenthetically I've accepted every job
but one that I've ever been offered so
I've had a very eclectic kind of
background and I sold cows happily until
somebody who purchased a herd of cattle
from me said Arthur if you can sell cows
the chances are you can probably sell
stock my son-in-law is starting a
brokerage firm would you like to join
him and I said of course the firm was
called Carter Berlin and while and it
grew like Topsy we acquired many firms
we changed our name twelve times during
the 13 years I was at the firm of the
starting partners of that firm Arthur
Carter runs the newspaper in New York
called the New York Observer Roger
Berlin is the most successful producer
on Broadway Sandy Weill as chairman of
Citigroup and I became a bureaucrat I
left there to run the American Stock
Exchange and then went back to my first
love which was journalism and acquired
and started a number of weekly
newspapers and magazines and then went
to Washington for eight of the most
exciting and productive years of my
professional life and I've often asked
myself and been asked why did I like it
so much before I came to Washington I
headed a business group of 100
high-growth CEOs and I use the typical
businessman's rhetoric talking about
Washington as being individuals who are
under worked and overpaid and it was a
revelation to me that of the 3,600
people who worked at the SEC the ones
that I came in contact with came to work
long before I did stayed long after made
a fraction of the money they could have
made in the private sector lawyers who
were earning an average of eighty to
ninety thousand dollars a year and whose
value in the marketplace today is over a
million dollars a year these were real
Patriots in my judgment they were there
because they believed passionately in
investor protection they believed in the
traditions of a commission that through
the years had been non partisan in its
approach to doing what was right for
America's markets and for America's
investors and they taught me a lot they
were dedicated loyal and committed
people I have a tendency to be impulsive
and I mean there are things that go on
in Washington I had a corporate
background so my background told me have
small short meetings but the
satisfaction that government employees
get is by being part of the process and
I didn't understand it at first when
when we were dealing with market
regulation the 15 people who headed that
division wanted to be in the room when a
decision was made and at first I didn't
want that to happen but I began to
understand that the compensation of
inclusiveness was far more important to
them than any amount of money that could
be paid to them and I came to feel
towards this group a an affection and a
feeling
I have not felt for any of the people
that I've ever worked with in any of my
career's I came to Washington believing
in markets to begin with and I derive
the satisfaction that I did because many
of the thoughts theories and concepts
that I embraced in my different careers
for the first time I could translate
into specific action in 1970 I gave a
speech at Columbia University while I
was the head of a firm called Shearson
Hayden stone where I cited the conflicts
of interest of brokers being paid on a
quantitative basis the conflicts of
interest in investment banking the
conflicts of interest in research my
partner said to me Arthur you're totally
impractical your Allah renzo Jones your
ideas would bankrupt us guess what I
came to the Commission with the same
ideas and I was able to implement those
ideas because they formed the basis of
an agenda that I was determined to
pursue in order to make the Commission
the most investor-friendly Commission in
the history of the agency now I said
that I believed in markets and maybe the
manifestation and an illustration of
what markets can be can best be
illustrated by another passion that I
have and that's without an endorsement I
am an absolute fanatical believer in
ebay i buy and sell hundreds of things
on ebay well about two years into the
job and my staff knew that I had this
affliction
all the men in this audience undoubtedly
have ties that you're tired of what can
you do with him you can't give them away
eventually they clog up your closet
until the point you throw them away well
not me I put up six ties on ebay for
sale now when you put something up on
ebay potential buyers send you emails
asking about do the ties have any spots
on them that's okay then I had one we
said by the way you're selling your toys
would you have a size nine and a half
brown left shoe curious and the next one
said would you have rousers to a gray
striped suit size 48 totally eccentric
the ties were sold and for a pretty good
price the next day I had six councils in
my office lawyers that worked for me and
one of them came in with some papers and
he looked vaguely familiar to me and I i
saw that tie I know that time then the
second came in and the third these guys
had all been on my ties it was the
greatest gag ever pull down
well
that's a rigged market and that's the
kind of market that we don't want to
have any part of in this country and the
SEC is there to see to it that the
market operates fairly the initiatives
that we pursued that I felt were the
most meaningful to the system included
banning the practice of pay-to-play and
again this relates to experiences that I
had when I traveled around the country
as an investment banker and went to
different communities to underwrite
their municipal bonds and was told well
we'll put you on the list if you agree
to buy a table at the state Republican
dinner or buy two tables at the County
Democratic dinner and was just obscene
in the way that business was bought and
sold and we were successful in passing a
rule which banned the practice and of
course the politicians fought us tooth
and nail brought a case that wound up in
the Supreme Court of the United States
which we won and today the practice of
giving political contributions to
officials in a position of awarding
those contracts by anyone in the
brokerage business has been outlawed and
by and large that practice has been
banned the next practice which my
experience really equipped me to deal
with was what was going on in the
over-the-counter markets we're during my
years in running a brokerage firm when I
saw over-the-counter securities we're 30
or 40 market makers we're giving almost
precisely the same quote in the same
spread
which was very large we brought an
action against the over-the-counter
market makers together with the Justice
Department for collusion it was a tough
fight the brokerage industry dealt with
me like a traitor to a business that I
had been part of but I felt this was a
basic and fundamental violation of
investors rights as a result of that
action the industry settled we were able
to change the trading practices and from
that day until this literally billions
of dollars a year have been transferred
from the pockets of brokers into the
pockets of investors as a result of
narrower spreads another incidence of
experience being part of this job was
when I tried to persuade companies to
allow my firm to underwrite their
securities CEOs of those companies would
say to me well Arthur will consider it
will consider it if you give us research
coverage now what's research coverage I
assure you it's not sell recommendations
and that game was played and in turn
analysts would be importuned by
companies to give them favorable ratings
and in return for which companies would
share with them information that was not
generally available to the investing
public so we embarked on a rulemaking
that resulted in regulation fair
disclosure reg FD as it came to be known
was bitterly opposed by the securities
industry the analysts community almost
universally opposed this regulation the
regulation called for any material
information
about a publicly owned company must be
released at the same time to the public
as well as to institutions as well as
the analyst community by and large
corporate America embraced this as
practices which they had adhered to
anyway and that was a terribly important
regulation now any of you who have been
part of government know that no matter
how well conceived a a rule or a
regulation may be almost always that
rule of regulation has unforeseen
consequences and it's the job of careful
regulators to measure that and make
mid-course adjustments another
rulemaking that we went through and
probably caused me the greatest
aggravation at any time that I was at
the Commission started about six months
after i came to the Commission if
someone had told me that most of my time
in Washington most of the eight years
would be spent dealing with accounting
issues I would have challenged them on
that I'm obviously not an accountant
never took an accounting course and have
the greatest admiration for those
hard-working people who are auditors but
I began to see more and more cases
coming through our enforcement division
of accounting fraud of numbers that were
manipulated and massaged this was not
just the accountants it was corporate
America that got caught up in the hype
and euphoria of a 15-year bull market
please forgive me these are that
virtually the first words I've spoken
I've just gotten rid of terrible case of
laryngitis I went to the firm's and I
tried to persuade them that it was
essential that they rid themselves of
the kinds of conflicts that were
creating these problems the economics of
the accounting industry changed
dramatically during the period of the
80s and 90s firms that had derived most
of their revenues from auditing began to
derive more and more revenues from
non-audit services consulting services
and companies very often publicly owned
companies were paying perhaps four and
five times as much for consulting
services as they did for auditing
services now I know many of you and
particularly those in the accounting
department know that in order is not
formula at a typical audit calls for
perhaps 75 to a hundred judgment calls
subjective judgments that could either
favor management or could favor
shareholders where is that call likely
to be made in the event of a huge
consulting contract as you walk through
the airport in Detroit in laguardia at
LAX in San Francisco and looked at the
signs put up by the accounting
profession during the 90s you'd have a
very difficult time in determining what
business these people were in they
certainly weren't auditors you didn't
see people in green eyeshades they
didn't talk about trust they didn't talk
about integrity they didn't talk about
accuracy they talked in a language that
was almost mystical
about services and concepts that had no
relevance to the investing public you
don't see those signs anymore because
the accounting industry was led by
individuals who by being such fierce
competitors between themselves lost
sight of the basic franchise given to
them by the government to place the
public interest above all else and where
did they go or for help when we were
negotiating a settlement with the
industry they went directly to Congress
and spent millions of dollars hiring
lobbyists that harassed the SEC
mercilessly and threatened the funding
of the agency during my years in
Washington I don't think we ever
initiated a single pro investor
initiative that was not opposed by
various members of the Congress and the
Senate and the reason for that was that
campaign contributions had become so
major a part of life in Washington that
the notion of getting the oversight
committees of a regulating agency to
harass that agency and tie them up in an
endless series of hearings and letters
that most rules most regulations never
see the light of day a regulator can be
most effective however by using the
bully pulpit available to him by going
directly to the people from my years
outside of Washington I knew that the
view of Washington by most Americans is
that this is a place where bureaucrats
operate in
protected offices throwing down
regulations that are costly like
Thunderbolts from atop Mount Olympus and
I started a program of traveling around
the country and conducting town meetings
where people came out to ask me
questions at first 40 people came to
hear me in Cherry Valley New Jersey and
then it grew 500 people in Houston a
thousand people in Columbus we had 43 of
these meetings in Los Angeles we
attracted 8,000 people for two hours
they asked questions how to choose a
mutual fund how to choose a broker why
didn't you answer my letter that I sent
you four months ago but they
participated in the process and at each
and every one of these meetings I
brought a member of the Commission's
oversight committee a typical
congressman cannot draw a thousand
people to a town meeting and they were
impressed with that and I think because
of that we were given more leeway than
we might otherwise have had and we were
probably the most proactive commission
that has been around for many many years
but getting back to the accountants I
met with the heads of the big five firms
at that time and asked them if they
would compromise the issue of separating
accounting auditing from consulting
services the then-head of Arthur
Andersen stood up at that meeting and
said if you go ahead with this Arthur
this will be war and war it was I think
they were foolish because we immediately
called for a series of public hearings
around America we're businesspeople
academics politicians consumerist all
got up and testify
to the fact that the accounting industry
had violated the contract that they had
with America they suffered a perceptual
blow of enormous magnitude I remember
going to my dentist in Washington around
that period and as I ease myself into
the chair of pain the dentist turned to
me and said you know Arthur those
accounts are sure a bunch of burglars
aren't they well when dentist start to
talk about accountants that way you know
you've got a problem well as we came to
the last part of that rule making
process we were threatened literally the
lifeline of the Commission was
threatened I've learned that in
Washington your friends may have very
different ideologies than you have and
indeed my closest relationships in
Washington my closest friend was with
senator phil gramm we agreed on nothing
absolutely nothing except we both loved
labrador retrievers and phil gramm was
the head of the powerful banking
committee when he heard that there was
an effort afoot to cut the funding of
the SEC if we proceeded with this
rulemaking he said to me Arthur I
disagree with you totally on this
proposal but I will fight to my last
breath to prevent legislative sleight of
hand from standing in your way senator
ted stevens of alaska another
conservative Republican and Judd Gregg
of New Hampshire all rose to the defense
of the Commission but if I had to name
individuals in Washington who really
cared about America's investors I could
probably not get
yes the fingers of my right hand
tomorrow morning on Capitol Hill there
will be lobbyists the New York Stock
Exchange lobbyists for the accounting
firms the law firms lobbyists for
corporate America but nobody will be
representing the interests of what is
potentially the most influential force
in the country and that's America's
investing public one of the reasons that
I wrote this book was to persuade
investors that their interests are very
much involved and that they simply have
to organize better than they have
through groups such as the consumers
Federation of America AARP the AF of
l-cio The Motley Fool and other groups
of that caliber and I think that is
beginning to take place in the absence
of that there are so many evidences of
Congress really neglecting investor
interests yes there are some members of
the House people like John Dingell who
represents this area Ed Markey and a su
from California and a number of others
who care about these issues but very few
members of Congress understand issues of
market structure or market regulation or
even investor protection and the
congressman who in recent months sound
like latter-day Elmer Gantry xand
calling for rules and regulations most
of which make no sense at all and are
overly costly they're the very ones who
tried to choke the SEC and they're the
ones as the passion for reform abates
will be back in their mode of doing
what's best for their contributors so it
was my hope that this
book in touching on the seven deadly
sins of mutual funds that not many fund
investors know about in talking about
alternatives you have to dealing with
brokers in talking about the plumbing in
terms of your options to choose a
different market on which to execute
your orders that investors might become
smarter investors I really believe that
a dollar spent on educating investors is
far more effective than a dollar spent
on regulation now all of this cascaded
once Enron came on the scene and
immediately the American public
galvanized the politicians to come up
with ideas and schemes and measures and
the finger of blame was pointed mostly
at the accountants also with the lawyers
but the blame doesn't just belong to the
accountants and the lawyers it's also
the standard setters the rating agencies
the regulators the boards of directors
and the public itself we all got caught
up in a period of hype euphoria where
disbelief was suspended and individuals
willing to pay a hundred times nothing
for companies that were worth just about
that were snapped up by a gullible
public and all of us had our share of
responsibility and now we're where we
are today we have an accounting
profession that has changed almost all
of its leadership they're beginning to
understand the relevance of the public
interest and I think that today's
leaders of the accounting
firms are trying to restore the
tarnished image of the profession
clearly the leaders of Corporate America
are aware of the essential importance of
the restoration of public confidence the
leaders of Corporate America during the
90s were the muscular leaders who would
buy a company with a stroke of a pen a
few months later fire 20,000 employees
and two or three years down the road
sell that company for a huge loss we
have in my judgment a different quality
of leadership in corporate America today
more sensitive more interested in public
private sector partnerships more
committed to restoring public confidence
we've been here before we were here
after teapot dome and after penn central
right now we're in a pretty good place
in my judgment in the economy and in our
markets and the public hasn't recognized
this yet they are frightened they are
disillusioned and by and large they
don't want to hear about the stock
market I think that I'm basically very
optimistic about our markets and where
we're going well I've covered a lot of
subjects I obviously care a lot about
these issues I'd like to stop now and
try to answer your questions which feel
free to ask me any easy question you can
about anything about my how I got my job
what my relationship with Bill Clinton
was what I think of how you what I think
of my success or just about anything you
want to ask I will try to answer for you
and I hope this motivates you to to buy
my book because if you don't I'll feel
rejected so I will try to answer those
questions yes dan why are with the mba
class of 03 I did not buy your book i
bought the cds okay and it's never too
late well well I bought him on ebay and
I plan to sell them again on ebay effect
but they were in their original wrapper
just wondering about your opinion about
the cut the question of deduct ability
of dividends and whether or not there
might be another way other than making
them tax-deductible to make them not
double taxed and what your view is of
that I think that the short term
implications in my judgment of the bill
as it's been presented or the outline of
it that the president gave will not be
of much consequence I think the
long-term implications I think will
motivate a change in market behavior it
will be very costly in my judgment but I
think it will have a number of
implications which I think will be
favorable I think companies will begin
to think about the desirability of
paying dividends I think it will move us
somewhat away from the short term
investment perspective that we have in
this country
I think that investors will begin to
look at dividends differently than they
have in the past if this is intended as
device to jumpstart the economy I don't
think it's going to work if it's
intended as a device to change market
behavior which in my judgment it clearly
is not I think it will have some impact
which will be favorable I believe that
the bill is not going to pass in its
present form but I think it will some
aspects of it will be will be retained
do you have any view of the effort by
mutual funds to almost self regulate
themselves these days and that
Commission the question was do I have
any feeling about before you answer
could we get people who have questions
please to come to the platform there's
two microphones set up between the two
tiers if you would please just step up
to the microphone be prepared to answer
a question the question I was asked was
about the proposal floated by the SEC
last week and discussed today by the
commission of setting up a separate
self-regulatory organization for the
mutual fund industry I'm not comfortable
with that proposal self-regulation works
up to a point it works effectively only
if there is oversight and during my
years at the Commission we brought cases
against the new york stock exchange the
American Stock Exchange the Philadelphia
the Boston the pacific chicago and the
chicago board options exchange just
about every exchange in america for not
pursuing the interests of investors now
by and large we couldn't do it without
having self regulation but I think with
the doubling of the SEC budget they have
more than enough resources to do a
better job
of policing the mutual fund industry
particularly with respect to hidden fees
compensation of managers and a whole
host of other areas I just don't think
the establishment of another SRO is the
way to go
yes with the demise of Arthur Andersen
could you tell us what the changes are
that are taking place in the accounting
profession and whether it is adequate
for in the long term I believe that the
government's case against Arthur
Andersen was very unfortunate it was
unfortunate because Arthur Andersen
under paul volcker at that point had
committed to embrace a series of very
very constructive changes that would
have served as a model for the
profession as a whole when anderson
failed not only did thousands of people
who had nothing to do with the Enron
episode lose their jobs but competition
was reduced and the remaining big four
was much less willing to embrace the
sorts of changes that Andersen was going
to embrace as a result of Anderson's
demise and the Enron debacle Congress
came up with the proposal to create an
accounting oversight board made up of
individuals of integrity who understood
the issues and could take over the
responsibility here 24 performed by the
aicpa which is the cheerleading group
the trade group for the accounting
profession which has done a perfectly
miserable job of representing the
interests of America's accountants this
group would conduct peer reviews to see
to it that audits were accomplished
professionally and they would revise
review and recreate audit standards
which heretofore had been zealously
protected by the AICPA
now I think this group can be effective
it can be effective because the
accounting industry abdicated their
right to self regulation and called for
oversight now if this oversight is fair
and effective I think over a period of
time the industry could be given back
its right to self regulation the key to
all of this I believe is the kind of
person that bill Donaldson the next
chairman of the SEC will choose to head
that oversight body the person in my
judgment should be someone of such
integrity and probity that he or she but
broadly be recognized by the American
public as someone who really had their
interests at heart I think that the
profession itself under the
sarbanes-oxley Act has begun the process
of divested itself of much of their
consulting work much of their tax work
and many of the conflicts that afflicted
them I have a piece that will run
shortly in the wall street journal on
exactly those areas of sarbanes-oxley
that I think represent real investor
protection and real benefits yes we've
talked about and the American public
they're concerned about the pay-to-play
concept with them analysts on Wall
Street and then there's a conflict of
interest between audits and consulting
some argue that there is a conflict of
interest in terms of pay to play with
industry analyst and tech firms and
other types of companies in terms of you
by research from certain analyst firms
and they'll start to write up and talk
about your products and everything could
you shed light on
where you see us addressing this type of
conflict and it is there as a conflict
from your perspective yeah I think there
is a conflict and as I think back of my
days the sec I could have done more on
this issue that I did and I understood
the conflict at that time having headed
a brokerage firm in a stock exchange but
I was so obsessed with other issues that
I relied on the NASD and the New York
Stock Exchange to address the issue and
only when it became a national scandal
was action taken on this issue but like
anybody else analysts became very
closely allied to companies that they
covered which were willing to give them
additional information the economics of
the brokerage business changed after
fixed Commission's were abandoned and
now no longer was retail brokerage the
principal financial driver behind most
brokerage firms and corporate finance
became the most important source of
revenue and analysts became adjuncts of
the corporate finance department rather
than of the retail sales department
analysts went out and made pitches i
presently serve on the boards of several
private companies one of which was
seeking a public offering and of the
five firms that made presentations to us
five of those presentations were made by
analysts not by people in the corporate
finance department and that's wrong now
what do we do about it well
the Attorney General of the state of New
York who has been criticized broadly I
think did something that was very
constructive and very creative and very
innovative the SEC was in the midst of a
huge political controversy and clearly
distracted from a number of issues he
took advantage of a law in the state of
New York that enabled him to bring an
action against firms for literally for
making fraudulent use of their research
analysts and that resulted in a
settlement where the firm's made certain
commitments to split off research from
Investment Banking to see to it that
investment banking didn't pay the
analysts and so forth I think as far as
it went that was constructive but the
millions of dollars in penalties paid by
the firms in my judgment was trivial was
meaningless but the only real benefit of
such an action comes from the public
perception of wrongdoing that went on in
this industry we don't know yet how all
of this is going to play out the
settlement still has not called for an
admission on the part of the firms as to
what they did I doubt that that
admission will go into every detail of
what they did and that would be the real
value of a settlement a true confession
of abuse a true confession of wrongdoing
if you move the research department as a
number of firms have done from the 31st
floor to the 16th floor and give it
another boss you know it may diminish
the conflict if it's in the same firm
under the same roof with the
same economics the perceptual conflict
of is there and I think that's wrong and
I think the only response is a total
separation of research and investment
banking and that is not likely to happen
what is likely to happen I believe is
the growth of a number of specialized
research firms that have already grown
up and can charge fees for quality
research which would be viewed with the
kind of attention that ratings by rating
agencies receive today it will be kind
of a stamp of approval so I think the
situation is better it is far from being
cured and sell-side research still
enjoys a fairly dim reputation I'll try
to give shorter answers what is your
opinion about Senator Grassley's recent
letter to President Bush and some
members of the SEC about disclosing tax
returns to investors do you think that
would help them or make them more
confused you know I didn't hear that
could you repeat that what is your
opinion about Senator Grassley's recent
letter to President Bush and some
members of the SEC about disclosing tax
returns or tax return information to
investors do you think that would help
investors or just make them more
confused I can't think of any kind of
disclosure any kind of disclosure that i
think would not be useful for investors
our markets are based on full and fair
disclosure not merit regulation and the
traditional business argument against
disclosure is it would confuse investors
we don't want to show the portfolio's of
mutual funds more than once a year that
would confuse investors we don't want to
reveal the proxy votes of mutual funds
that would burden investors I don't buy
that so I'm supportive of
a call for greater disclosure crisis and
confidence is multifaceted how would you
align the resources of the SEC and set
the priorities of the SEC if you were in
Bill Donaldson shoes read my column in
The Wall Street Journal but I think
first of all technology has to be used
more effectively by the Commission the
fact that when the World Trade Center
blew up the Commission lost all of the
records of all of the cases in its
second most important office and simply
didn't have the technology to replicate
those records the fact that the division
of corporation finance is so back backed
up that they can review filings only
once every five years which is
tantamount to no review at all we need
technology to address that issue the
Commission needs additional trial
attorneys to bring cases they need
technology to address internet fraud
they need many more accountants and the
market for accounts today for those of
you that are studying accounting you
have entered the Garden of Eden you
accountants are more sought after today
than just about anyone else in the
business community and the Commission
needs them badly and unfortunately can't
pay them as much as they can get in the
private sector the Commission needs more
funds for investor education as I said
before a dollar spent in educating
investors is far more useful than a
dollar spent in regulating our markets I
think the issue of deciding what
accounting standards are going to be and
how will the Commission prevent
additional accounting fraud is terribly
important
I think perhaps the most important
mission for the Commission is to revise
the way America's accounting standards
are set we've had the independent
standard setter the fasb setting
accounting standards but being funded by
the very organizations the very business
groups for whom they're setting
standards that conflict has created
enormous bureaucracy and the way
accounting standards have been set and
now that Congress has provided the
funding for an independent fasb i hope
the Commission can work with the fasb to
see to it that their process of standard
setting becomes speedier more relevant
more understandable and most importantly
we should be moving toward international
accounting standards Paul Volcker and
the International Accounting Standards
Board are doing a darn good job in
setting accounting standards
particularly with respect to the
expensing of stock options I hope the
fasb follow suits and I hope that we are
able to harmonize accounting standards
using the best of us standards and some
of the best standards that are out there
in the past we could always assume if
its US GAAP it's got to be right well
Enron Anderson changed a lot of things
and I don't think we can afford to say
just because it's here just because it's
gap it's right we still have the best
markets of any in the world the best
standards the best process but we still
can learn a lot and make adjustments in
where we are now you ask me about my
relationship with President Clinton
and that's an interesting question i had
at the commission as my predecessors and
successors add about 25 political
appointees now political appointees are
those that traditionally come from the
party in power and are cleared by the
White House personnel office at the
Commission some 16 or 17 of the people
that I appointed to those offices were
either independence or Republicans and
the Clinton White House did not object
to a single one of them never sent me
any one that had been active in a
campaign to employ and greatly respected
the independence of the agency at a time
when our funding was jeopardized I went
to Larry Summers and told him that our
bill is combined with a lot of important
bills and I know the pressure on
President Clinton to sign that bill will
be enormous but I hope you can get him
to agree to veto the bill if the
viability of the SEC is placed in
question within several hours Larry came
back and said the president has agreed
to do it he was enormously supportive I
met with him alone just about the only
time that I did meet with him alone a
day or so before he left office and
after the usual kind of formalities I
said mr. president you know I wondered
why I haven't heard from you more or
seen more of you during eight years I've
been here we've certainly been involved
in a lot of issues some of them were
pretty tough for you in terms of
the politics of the issue and I just
wondered if you felt about me as you
might a postmaster in Little Rock any
smile then he said no he said with you
and Bob Rubin Larry Summers and some of
the others that I knew knew one another
in private life and were real
professionals I respected you and I
wanted to allow you to do your job and I
think that intelligence and that
sensitivity produced a darn good
economic team and the fact that Reuben
and I and Greenspan had known one
another for many years really helped
policy-making when you get to Washington
your staff is inclined to tell you well
you can't trust Treasury or you can't
trust the controllers office they'll eat
your lunch and they'll play on the turf
battles well they couldn't do that with
us because we knew one another too well
and I think that element of trust really
helped America's markets so thank you
for that very perceptive question
anything else yes I have a question
about investor protection and the
relationship between the unsophisticated
investor and a broker my question is
whether in your view full disclosure is
adequately met by a broker sending a
prospectus with a trade confirmation and
if that's not adequate what what is the
industry standard or if it's if the
industry standard is has some
shortcomings what should it be well I
having been a broker having seen the
conflicts that brokers and firms go
through i feel that most investors
should if they have a broker that's
charging commissions should fire that
broker which is the heading of chapter
one but i think we are leaving the era
of the commission broker and entering an
era of financial advisor i think most
investors would do well most investors
in the first place should in my judgment
be in low expense ratio mutual funds
index funds that mirror the performance
of the market as a whole but an investor
who has substantially larger amounts of
money should seek an investment advisor
or a broker who charges an annual fee as
far as the protections are concerned
there's a lot that doesn't come across
in the prospectus or in the confirmation
like
how much if it's a principal transaction
a security that a bond that has been
inventoried by the firm what their
profit might be like whether the broker
is being paid a commission and if so how
much what market was the order executed
on there's a great many things that is
there a contest that the broker is
participating in where his Commission's
might send him to Honolulu so I think
disclosure can go a lot further and I
think the conflicts that the firms have
are beginning to diminish some firms are
doing better than others and I think
that the real quality to look for in a
broker is how smart is that broker how
well does he know the products that he's
selling so many new products are
available today yes what are your
thoughts on the relationship between the
Bush administration and the SEC the
relationship between the Bush
administration and the SEC I think the
president has gone along with a
substantial increase in the budget of
the SEC he has spoken about the
importance of stamping out fraud in our
markets has put the prestige of the
administration behind the Commission and
I think you can ask for no more from an
administration and I applaud the
initiatives that he has embraced
yes my ibanking colleagues are gonna
dislike this question flawed in the
sense that prices are set deliberately
low money's left on the table from a for
the company that's going public and
retail investors are generally shut out
what is your opinion on that and do you
think government and the SEC
specifically has a role in helping to
change that and make it more efficient
I'm often asked this question about the
fact that I POS initial public offerings
wind up in the hands of institutions and
very little of it goes to retail
investors well I don't think the process
of allocating I POS the basic process of
allocating it to your best customer is
wrong I think that's a standard and a
reasonable business practice I believe
that if there is if there are payments
involve for those allocations if
investors are expected to buy in the
aftermarket or buy at higher prices
that's a manipulative practice and
that's a practice that is a violation of
the securities laws and those instances
have been under investigation and I
think you will see cases brought by the
Commission as they should be I think
that the practice of using research to
hype companies that really are
undeserving of that is wrong and I think
American investors have to be far more
questioning about buying IPOs I think
anyone who makes the purchase of IPOs
the basis of their investing strategy
deserves to lose their money it's a dumb
strategy most IPOs don't work out
and it's the greed factor at work and I
don't have much sympathy for investors
who play that game and then complain
because they find that they've lost
money but to the extent to which there
have been manipulations that have taken
place that is that is totally wrong
hi exactly a question that I have is you
mentioned several times about investor
education and I know your book is one of
the ways to educate and University of
Michigan could you be a little bit more
specific as to what other area that we
could become a better private investor
well I can't think of a better area than
investor education I think that with
respect to 401ks that's the greatest
universe of uneducated investors in the
world the Labor Department simply lacks
the resources to do what they should do
to teach investors on which options
should be pursued and how to understand
when a proxy is really reveals a
terrible flaw in a company and I think
that process of education is not
something that can necessarily be taught
in high schools or universities or
graduate schools it's pretty pretty
obvious pretty plain and i think that
the SEC has begun that process and
should continue it I think the town
meetings allowing investors to ask
questions is a pretty good way of doing
it I think that investor protection in
this country is a function of kind of a
trilogy of three things the enforcement
efforts of the SEC to bring actions
against violations of our security laws
they can't assure investors against all
fraud but they can see the most common
cases internet fraud for instance and
they can come down hard on those cases
making them a symbol for what investors
should avoid secondly
the work of the self-regulating
organizations the work of the New York
Stock Exchange and the NASD whose
enforcement arm is has become
increasingly sophisticated to protect
investors the NASD is about to bring a
major case involving research on its
misuse and finally private rights of
action the rights of individuals to sue
under our securities laws when they have
been defrauded and those three elements
private rights of action SROs and the
enforcement efforts of the SEC in my
judgment give us the best protected
universe of investors and the best
protected markets in the history of the
world yes
I have any of the problems you've talked
about tonight been increased or enabled
by the Securities Reform Act of nineteen
ninety five and have any of the
provisions of that been repealed the
Securities Reform Act that of 1995 that
I was just asked about the question was
whether any of the problems resulted
from that act which to some extent made
it somewhat more difficult to bring
frivolous lawsuits I don't really
believe so I think there were some
aspects of that act that were productive
I think that the SEC tried to see to it
that investor interests were protected
and I think the greatest fears that we
had were not realized the act as it was
originally constructed called for losers
to pay for litigation and I oppose that
strenuously because I felt that would
simply say that people who didn't have
money simply couldn't afford to sue and
I think that's a an essential protection
and the Act didn't include that I do not
personally believe the litigation reform
act brought about what we have
experienced in recent months and years I
think what brought about what we've
experienced in recent months and years
has been the failure of all our
gatekeepers and what I referred you
before as the suspension of disbelief by
a public that was willing to go along
with anything by research analysts who
saw every recommendation go up by
investment bankers who saw every
underwriting succeed by brokers or so
recommendation go up in all of these
energies thought it was their genius
that produce these results rather than
the sweep of a bull market which carried
a lot of bad stuff along with a lot of
good
well you've been a great audience I
won't ask you any additional questions I
hope that some of you buy my book but
more importantly than that I hope you
kind of carry the message ask the
questions find out whether you're your
Congressman your senator cares read
proxy statements look for boards that
are corrupted we've got lots of them
because you know the American people are
a friendly people we're a collegial
people and when we're invited to go on
boards we tend to go if we know people
on those boards or ave serve on our
boards and how likely are we to raise
our hands and object well before Enron
Anderson not very likely today I think
audit committees and boards of directors
have been put on notice and I'm very
often challenged with well it's going to
be so hard to get directors today it
will and it should be because directors
have a great and almost sacred
responsibility and they're basically the
lifeline in terms of investor protection
that will do much more than any of the
rules or congressional fulminations or
anything we write about or speak about
and some of you serve on boards will
serve on boards no board members and
I hope you won't despair you'll ask the
tough questions and you'll keep coming
back thanks a lot
Arthur Levitt served as chairman of the
SEC during the Clinton administration
from nineteen ninety three to two
thousand his book is take on the street
what Wall Street in corporate America
don't want you to know what you can do
to fight back it's published by Pantheon
books an imprint of Random House visit
them online at Random House calm /
pantheon monday is President's Day and
you're watching a three-day weekend of
books on book